well my family is from the south and
when I went to grad school at Yale and
decided to start working on prisons
because as an undergrad I had noticed
you know there's all this money going
into prisons and it's starting to a clit
was starting at that time already to
eclipse higher education spending in
many states but when I started kind of
going through the literature I realized
you know almost all the books were
really focusing on the north there was a
lot of new books and research coming out
about California but the south is really
where the action was three-fifths of the
prison growth in the US in the last 30
years has been in the south the south
overwhelmingly and to a lesser extent
the Sun Belt have the highest rates of
incarceration in the country and there
hadn't been much attention there so I
went down to my own state where I spent
a lot of time Mississippi and thought
about doing research there and then I
spent time at the Angola padana prison
plantation in Louisiana but the more I
kind of started poking around the more I
realized that Texas is really where the
action is you know just like if you're
going to do film studies you probably
are going to end up in Hollywood or
study finance you're going to end up in
New York Texas has now the largest penal
system in the United States hundred and
seventy one thousand people behind bars
that's more than California even though
California has a third larger population
those under some sort of criminal
justice supervision including parole and
probation that gets up around 750,000 in
Texas which makes it you know about the
same size as the booming capital Austin
it's got obviously the most active death
chamber in the nation the most
aggressive private prison industry um
Texas is also politically really
important you know because Bush the
second was president when I started this
project and a lot of recent presidents
have come from Texas Eisenhower and
Johnson and and both bushes so I felt
that Texas was a place where we can see
the southern influence of criminal
justice on the nation because it's a
kind of bridge between the deep south
and the west and
midwest and it really was where the
action was and I think that was it was
kind of the right place to look because
I think looking carefully at the history
of Texas kind of makes us rethink the
history of crime and punishment and
incarceration in the country as a whole
the sentences tend to be longer the the
protections for indigent defendants so
on the entry side tend to be weaker
Texas has although it's that's starting
to change now but there's no statewide
public defender system so most of the
public defenders are appointed by judges
and they're paid a kind of set amount
for the case which means that the less
work they do on behalf of a defendant
the more they will make as an hourly
wage there's all sorts of you know
court-appointed attorneys who are doing
working really hard but they are
penalized for doing so and the judges
are also elected in Texas which has
meant that it in the kind of resurgence
of conservatism that has seized on law
and order as a central campaign slogan
and as candidates from you know Bush the
first using Willie Horton against
Dukakis forward have found that attack
ads based on accusing someone of being
soft on crime are pretty effective it's
meant that most of the judges elected to
the criminal appellate courts and to the
local courts have been lon or order
conservatives often prosecutors or
victims rights advocates and so the
judiciary in Texas has kind of more
often wield at a rubber stamp than a
gavel and so that accounts for some of
the higher rates of incarceration and
that accounts that explains a lot of why
Texas's death chamber is so much more
active Texas doesn't have the largest
death row it's not sentencing more
people to death although there are a lot
of people being sentenced to death
because they're not getting good
representation but the appellate courts
are so harsh in Texas so much so that
even the US Supreme Court which is now a
very conservative body has repeatedly
over the last few years been rebuking
the Texas Court of Criminal Appeals I
mean they've they've made decisions that
to the rest of us seem sort of
unfathomable they allowed an execution
to go forward because without review
because the defense attorneys missed a
5pm filing deadline they've
used to release inmates who have been
proven twice innocent by DNA evidence
just a couple of weeks ago the Supreme
Court had to step in to stop the
execution of hank skinner because the
prosecutors had refused for years to
subject the physical evidence from his
crime scene to DNA testing and the list
kind of they refuse to order new trials
when it they found out that the judge
and the prosecutor had been sleeping
together during the defendants trial so
there's a whole series of kind of
outrageous decisions so it's a
confluence of factors but what I didn't
get to maybe we'll talk about later as
what I really actually argue in the book
is more that there is this historical
legacy of slavery and that we still live
within slavery and segregation shadow
and that really is what is governing and
propelling prison growth in the south
and now in the country as a whole
DNA testing has has led to a kind of
crisis in the judiciary because it is if
it's done properly which it often isn't
I mean the crime labs in Dallas and
Houston have been plagued by error and
prosecutorial bias but if the labs are
independent and fair and the training is
solid and and they're independent then
the results are so good that it has made
us realize that types of testimony types
of evidence that we thought were
unassailable like like eyewitness
testimony and in rape cases in which the
defendants with great convene in which
the victims with great conviction
believe that the person before them was
the assailant it has turned out in many
cases that they were wrong that app and
there's a lot of kind of cognitive
research now to back this up that we can
kind of plant memories or change
memories through the process of the
lineup and so on so yeah the more that
we can the more that we can provide
defendants in cases in which there is
physical evidence the best kind of
testing to ensure the most fairness
that's better and that's a way to reduce
frankly the prison population and to
save money in the long term as well I
mean I think having a robust robust
public defender system having a
genuinely adversarial criminal justice
system that will on the one hand stop
innocent people from going to prison but
also there's a much larger category of
gray areas where people are going down
for or pleading to sentences that are
much longer than they would have gotten
even if they were guilty had all of the
investigative and mitigating factors
come to the fore with adequate defense
representation that's a way to reduce
the prison population and it's a way to
do it in such a way that might not
entail as much political peril as some
early release programs if they're not
done carefully because that always of
course will generate some portion of
ghastly headlines
that has to do I think primarily with
the way that both indigent defense is
handled in Texas and the appellate
courts are organized indigent defense
it's court-appointed rather than a
public defender system although there
there have been some improvements in the
last couple of years so about
court-appointed attorneys in Harris
County which is the death penalty
epicenter of the United States they
don't have their own evidence budgets
they don't have salaries they are
penalized economically if they work
really hard on a case and so there's a
kind of assembly line quality to the
convictions and then worse the elected
judges at the appellate level have let
all sorts of cases go through and and
indeed you know we have now pretty much
irrefutable evidence that Texas in
recent years with all of the Criminal
Procedure improvements since the Warren
and the burger courts that have been
executed who were innocent notably
Cameron Todd Willingham who was one of
my research subjects and we corresponded
for a long time he was profiled in the
New Yorker I myself I must confess
because I have young children and he was
convicted of burning alive his two
daughters in order to collect insurance
money I always felt a little queasy
corresponding with him I never really
believed believed his constant
professions of innocence but luckily
somebody did start looking into it and
once they hired minimally competent
arson investigators to go over the
physical evidence and once they had
people go back and look at the witness
testimony when they were first
interviewed by police vs what they said
on the stand they were able to show that
a there's no evidence of arson
whatsoever be there's no serious motive
in books of the insurance settlement was
was poultry and and all of the kind of
evidence of him being kind of dangerous
was also dubious and generated by
prosecutorial coaching
and everybody who's looked at that case
is now convinced that Willingham was
innocent the Texas forensic science
Commission was about to a couple of
months ago declare that he had been
wrongly executed governor Ryan in
Illinois when this happened under his
watch to his credit he was a pro death
penalty Republican he was so troubled by
the prospect of executing innocence that
he vacated death row and ordered a
really high level investigation of the
entire death row and it resulted in a
lot more exonerations and he commuted a
lot of those sentences to life in prison
and some lessons some people walked free
Governor Perry longest-serving governor
in Texas history executed under his
watch more people than any other
governor quite possibly in American
history he took a different approach
when the evidence became clear that a
innocent person had been executed under
his watch he fired the members of the
forensic science Commission and replaced
it with his cronies such that the truth
would be squashed and that's kind of a
that's a pattern of his in the past is
to pursue policy ideologically based and
to ignore truth and evidence